the central dogma of molecular biology
dictates the flow of genetic information
from dna to rna and then to protein
in order to create proteins from these
genes rna copies are made in the nucleus
and will be subsequently transported
into the cytosol where proteins are
built based on their sequences
in other words for protein coding genes
rna is made from dna during a process
called transcription and protein is made
from rna during translation
there are different methods available
for detecting and quantifying gene
expression
reverse transcription pcr or rtpcr
amplifies dna based on two primer
sequences framing the section of
interest
since pcr amplifies dna and not rna rna
is first converted back to dna prior to
amplification
this is done via a process called
reverse transcription
in nature this process is carried out by
retroviruses
in northern blotting an rna sample is
digested into fragments that are
separated by size in a gel using
electrophoresis
they are then transferred to a membrane
that can be probed to test for the
presence of a hypothesized rna
transcript
microarrays like northern blots are
hybridization based
but in contrast to a northern blot a
microarray yields highly detailed
information about the individual genes
that have been transcribed
these signals are then detected
quantified and used to create a digital
image of the array
finally the digital image is used to
identify the transcribed genes
protein-coding genes in genomic dna
contain large stretches of non-coding
sequences called introns that are
spliced out of the rna transcript by an
enzymatic complex called the spliceosome
before it is passed to the ribosome for
translation
the parts of the gene that remain in the
mature processed mrna transcript are
called exons
these are the parts that encode the
amino acid sequences and will be used in
protein production
next generation sequencing technology
allows for advanced studies of gene
expression because it captures a
snapshot of the whole transcriptome
rather than a predetermined subset of
genes which was previously possible with
rtpcr and microarray technologies
whole transcriptome sequencing provides
a comprehensive view of the cellular
transcriptional profile at any given
biological moment and greatly enhances
the power of rna discovery methods
to study this data we have to run
processing pipelines that turn raw reads
into structured data ready for analysis
ngs technology captures dna sequences
and generates digital data using several
steps
first rna that was extracted from cells
is converted into cdna that is then
sheared and placed into a flow cell
inside the flow cell cdna fragments are
amplified using bridge pcr amplification
and the flow cell is then inserted into
the sequencer
this machine uses image analysis to
capture each letter in the flow cell
fragments by analyzing visual patterns
and then converting them into a sequence
of letters
typically ngs reads are between 30 and
300 base pairs long they consist of a
series of letters t
c
g and a
recall that a typical rna-seq pipeline
includes three main steps pre-processing
mapping and quantification
pre-processing is needed to clean up our
data by removing the adapters trimming
some of the reeds and removing the pcr
duplicates
this is important because pcr
amplification is not uniform across all
reads
then we take the cleaned up read
sequences to map them onto a reference
using a fasta file for sequences of the
genome and gtf files for annotation
based on the quality of annotation we
can use various strategies for mapping
once this step is complete we have to
quantify expression levels and give each
expressed element a number
this process helps transform short raw
reads that are in the fastq file into
structured tables of gene or isoform
expression that can be analyzed for
expression patterns